[Music]
hello friends I'm Lucy and welcome to
reality check you might remember that
before the days of the base building
super mutant shooting time sync that is
fallible I made an episode of this very
show all about what would actually
happen to the ecosystem of the world if
nuclear bombs were to fall if you
haven't seen it I'll pop a link at the
end of the episode so you can take a
look see I thought it'd be interesting
to do a couple of follow-up episodes all
around nuclear war wasteland life and
other really cheery scenarios this week
though let's tackle how we would survive
a nuclear blast in the 1950s and 60s the
threat of a nuclear war was so ingrained
in the public consciousness that nuclear
safety drills were taught in schools and
educational segments were even
broadcasted on radio set to popular show
tunes so basically just one step away
from having cheery vault-tec employees
selling us promises of safety door to
door but in the boring old real world
where access to life preserving yet
ethically dubious vault isn't really
possible what would US average joes do
well luckily for us we have two good
sources too drawn to see how we'd fair
the first from atmospheric scientist
Michael Dillon who has spent years
figuring out survival methods for just
such an occasion we can also anticipate
what to expect from the planning
guidance for response to a nuclear
detonation from the and brace yourself
national security staff into agency
policy coordination subcommittee for
preparedness and response to
radiological and nuclear threats and
good grief that's a long title for a
committee it's worth bearing in mind the
dillon stuff is purely theoretical and
based on nukes with yields between no
point 1 to 10 kilo tons so for
comparisons sake the bombs dropped on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki in World War two
had yields of between 15 and 20 1 kilo
tons and the yields of the bombs in
fallouts Great War are between two
hundred and seven hundred and fifty kilo
tons for the purposes of this video we
will be going with dylan's calculations
even if they're smaller range nukes but
it's worth bearing in mind that some of
these techniques have been used when
there's been more powerful detonations
so the alarms blare the nukes are
falling what's actually happening well
first up they'll be the black
a rapidly expanding fireball which
generates a pressure wave that moves
away from the point of detonation now
the blast wave moves relatively slowly
once it gets about a mile away from
Ground Zero it'll take roughly five
seconds to cover each mile but on top of
this the blast wave also generates high
winds reaching up to 160 miles an hour
with a 10 kiloton explosion add this all
together and in the immediate blast zone
you're looking at massive damage to
buildings fires and a ninety percent
plus likelihood of instant death for a
10 kiloton nuke you'll be in immediate
radiation danger if you're less than a
kilometer away from Ground Zero and at
risk from fallout contamination from 10
to 20 miles away but let's say you're
over a mile out you see the flash hear
the bang what do you do well in the
1950s at the height of the Atomic Age at
least you'd get under the table this
traces back to World War one where
countries like the US the USSR Germany
and the UK came up with basic civil
defense practices to teach civilians how
to protect themselves in the likelihood
of a military attack the phrase duck and
cover was everything and it was famously
made into a cartoon we're careful Bert
the turtle taught some rather nonplussed
children about how to survive in the
event of atomic and my elation they were
told get indoors do not look at the
flash get away from windows cower under
sturdy door frames or tables and to
cover their skin it sounds like common
sense and it is but you can't deny its
effectiveness unless you're right next
to ground zero but you know we already
covered that people as close to 170
meters to ground zero at Hiroshima and
Nagasaki managed to survive the blast
purely because they were inside
reinforced concrete buildings survivor
mio komatsu barra immediately dropped to
the floor when she saw the blast and
said that she saw those who were still
standing simply get blown away in Russia
school teacher Yulia kibosh ever saw the
flash room was ultimately called that
Chelyabinsk meteor explosion she ordered
all of her students to duck and cover
not a single one of those children got
injured whereas Yulia got caught up
quite badly by the imploding glass
because she was near a window and she
didn't get down in time its natural
human instinct to want to see what
causes big loud bangs or find the source
of a flash but the truth is nuclear
explode
are such an intense source of light than
looking directly at the thermal flash
even from 15 miles away can cause
temporary or even permanent blindness so
try and fight the urge to look another
thing to take into account is your
clothing by using it to cover as much of
your skin as possible you're less
susceptible to flash burns from the
blast with a 10 kiloton explosion you
can still get burned up to two miles
away from the blast zone so cover up but
after things have died down remember
that your clothing is likely to be
coated in radioactive contamination
especially if you are outside during the
blast take it off and shower with soap
if you can so you've taken shelter how
long do you stay there for referring
back to dylan's hypothetical scenario if
a bomb of around 10 kilo tons were to be
dropped and you're over half a mile away
from the blast radius he reckons you
need to wait about 30 minutes for the
initial radiation to dispel before
searching for adequate and preferably
thick concrete walls shelter from there
wait for between 12 to 24 hours because
the blast isn't the last of it angry
dangerous radioactive particles are
gonna start raining down from the sky
and this is what's known as fallout so
what's so bad about this early nuclear
fallout compared to other regular
fallout while exposure to radiation can
lead to cancer later in life but this
early fallout is the stuff that's really
dangerous in the short term these highly
radioactive particles are going to give
you radiation sickness pretty much
immediately which can range anywhere
from slight nausea to burning skin
dizziness headaches and with increased
exposure comes a higher likelihood of
death luckily and if luckily is a word
you can use in an atomic blast situation
a half-life of this early fallout is
relatively short and it decays quite
quickly which is why it may be possible
to go outside within a day or so but
Dylan and other experts do say that it's
best to wait from the okay from the
authorities before venturing out from
safety and then rebuild which is what
we'll be covering on the next episode
food supply water and maybe even some
basic survival techniques basically it's
way more difficult than fallout mix it
look if you missed the last radioactive
episode then check the link on your
screen now to give it a look that's all
for this week reality check will return
in two weeks time thanks for watching
don't forget
twitter at least James games and I'll
see you next time
[Music]